مره اخرى مجموعات المعارضه الكرديه
الايرانيه في اقليم كردستان العراق امام
فوهه نيران طهران الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
تتهم هذه المجموعات باثاره المظاهرات التي
تشهدها ايران وتزعم انها ترسل اسلحه
ومقاتلين
الاسلاميه تعمل على اساس حقوقها القانونيه
لحمايه امن حدودها وتوفير الامن وصد
التهديدات
شهدي لا يمكن الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستانيه الايراني الدعمه للمتظاهرين
في ايران
لكنهم المقابل يرفض اتهامات طهران
الاحزاب السياسيه في كردستان تمثل جزءا من
شعوري
المتظاهرين فهم ليسوا منفصلين عنا ولا نحن
نفصل عنهم
ان يكون العراق ساحه الاستراعات تؤكد على
ان اراضيها لن تكون مقرا او ممرا لالحاق
الضرر باي من دول الجوار القياده العسكريه
للشرق الاوسط تصف بدورها لهجمات الايرانيه
بالعشوائيه وبغير قانونيه وترى انها تعرض
المدنيين للخطر وتنتهي كل سياده العراق
وتقود امنه
هي ليست المره الاولى التي تستهدف فيها
طهران هذه المجموعه ولا يبدو انها ستكون
الاخيره اثر اعلان الحرس الثوري الايراني
بانه سيواصل ضرب الفصائل الكرديه المعارضه
في اقليم كردستان